do you know what jordan peterson thinks
about bitcoin and about the future
impact about of bitcoin and the society
no i don't actually um
we're hopefully going to be talking to
him soon about that
we did a book club on his book maps of
meaning and he engaged with us about it
so we're hoping to deliver the orange
pill to mr peterson
i think his audience um is one of the
most important audiences in the world to
understand bitcoin these
people that are conscientious and
responsible
um i think they'll quickly understand
bitcoin's value proposition and help
elucidate it to the world i'm trying to
remember what he said about
about it basically i think his support
of bitcoin
is grounded in the kind of people who
are opposing bitcoin
um so without understanding bitcoin
he starts to like bitcoin because of the
people who are opposing it
he's you know you start to i mean that's
partially why
i am interested in bitcoin it's like all
the people
in uh in power and all the kind of shady
fraudulent and non-genuine people
who are dismissing bitcoin yeah uh
are making me think hmm one of uh
jordan's definitions of god
is he says god is found in the truthful
speech
that rectifies pathological hierarchies
and i think that is a
beautiful definition of what bitcoin is
doing in the world
and that we have this pathological
hierarchy called central banking
by which the rich get richer and the
poor get poorer
um that is used as a mechanism for
perpetual theft
and funding warfare at a global scale
uh like ron paul said it's no
coincidence that the 20th century
of total war was also the century of
central banking
when you have an institution
of currency counterfeiting which the
central bank is
you are no longer bounded by your own
balance sheet when you go to war
you don't have to just go to war on your
own resources you can now pillage
the commonwealth and pull for the
savings of society
as a whole before you go bankrupt and
indeed this is what
hitler did right hitler hyperinflated
uh in the weimar republic to to fund his
war
efforts um and frankly every
dictator every world war every
internment camp
in history was made possible by
the weaponization of money in fiat
currency so i hope
i know jordan peterson is a huge
proponent of free speech
and i think that's ultimately at its
deepest essence that's what bitcoin
really is
right it is just the purest form of
monetary
speech we've ever had and by
purifying that primary operating system
of human action
i think we can eliminate this
pathological hierarchy
that is unfortunately the dominant
institution in the world today
yeah i'm definitely especially with
these explorations of bitcoin
this journey i've been on i'll revisit
some of the things
some of the aspects of human history
that i've been looking at like stalin
and hitler
with a from a perspective of a monetary
perspective
like what are the effects of inflation
how was it used as a tool in um
in gaining power and maintaining power
in
manipulating the populace in
doing um in inflicting suffering
and uh i would say evil onto the world
it's interesting i it's interesting
i'm gonna have to sort of go back into
the whole so i tend to
focus more on the human nature
and less about the tools that human
nature leverages
to affect change but you're right that
uh
in some sense money is uh
a tool which can be uh effectively used
to uh perform moral
and the moral actions depending on how
it's used and there's a feedback between
the two
right there's um
[Music]
specifically with money itself
it's
the and sin uh here's the way i've been
posing it lately is that i actually
think we typically think of people as
good or bad or
again trying to label people all the
time but i think people and their
characters are emergent properties
of the incentive structures they inhabit
yeah
so you know what does charlie munger say
don't
show me the incentives i'll show you the
outcome kind of thing
this is a flawed incentive structure
we've been operating within
now i'm not speaking to the intention
people want to argue with me all the
time like
jerome powell's not a bad guy he's doing
his best at the central bank he's doing
what he thinks is right
that's fine whether that's true or not
it actually doesn't matter
the intention is divergent from the
outcome the institution that they are
running is premised on deception and
theft
and it is handicapping the productive
economy so when we're even the terms we
use
printing money you're not creating any
new value you're not infusing the
economy with anything any new productive
factors whatsoever
you're just harvesting the economic
surplus created by entrepreneurs in the
marketplace
there's it's impossible to add any value
to an economy
by increasing the paper claims on its
savings
so um
there's a feedback loop between man and
tool between creator and created
and i think we have to honor the
relationship
above either one right trying to put the
right people in the system or just build
the right system we need both
do you think the interesting question
whether the people that
are in control of central banks or in
positions of power there
if they themselves are malevolent they
themselves are bad actors
or they're simply like leaves
floating along the river sort of just
the
cog uh in the machine
an ant and an ant colony that operates
in a certain kind of way
like where do you put the blame do you
put the blame
on the way things are operating onto the
individuals
or onto the system itself the idea
behind the system
where and is it useful to place the
blame somewhere
because for me it might be useful to
understand that in order to
figure out what the solution is i tend
to
not put the blame on the individual like
i tend to believe most
people are good and want to see
themselves as good
and so in that case it's very difficult
to be truly malevolent as you would need
to be to control
to gain centralized power at a large
scale
but i know a lot of conspiracy theory
theorists
and just a lot of people think that
there is evil
humans in the world that seek power
maintain that power and then use that
power for bad purposes
i think they're just people and they're
just trying to get something for nothing
like all of us do i like this framework
of thought
yeah honestly yeah and that's what the
central bank is is the ultimate
institution to get something for nothing
you yeah get a perpetual income stream
the ability to acquire more and more
territory in the world
through monopolizing the supply of money
and you can literally print money you
can buy your way out of anything and buy
your way into anything in the world
so it is i think the most
i'd say the most but a group of very
intelligent people put this thing
together and figured out how to get
something for nothing in perpetuity
um by clouding people's conception of
money
and you know if we look at the central
bank is
it's been around for a while but the
latest implementation
uh here in the us is the fed you know
it's about 100 years old it's an analog
age institution
that i think has lost a lot of its
relevance
in the modern age and i don't think it
will survive
the ever galvanizing gaze of the digital
age it's just too much sunlight
too much transparency today ideas move
too quickly for something like this to
remain relevant
but there are just people they are just
seeking something for nothing
but i think when you concentrate that
much power and that much control
not much wealth into the hands of few it
does
change uh hayek argued that the nature
of power
again it's something that we all sort of
desire we to be completely powerless
you're really unhappy right if you're
totally powerless you're a slave
someone else tells you what to do you
have no autonomy it's miserable
right so there's this it makes the
consolidation of power alluring
and that we want to protect ourselves
from that slave state let's say
but like many things it can be taken too
far
and when you concentrate power into too
few hands
hayek argues that it actually changes it
transforms it becomes something much
more intoxicating
than it would be if it was held in a
more distributed way
and i think that gets into a lot of
these
you know the i don't know if they call
themselves elites or people call them
elites or whatever like
um let's say shareholders or central
banks people participate in the world
economic forum things like this
they come i guess the incentives right
the incentive
schema they're in is rewarding them
constantly telling them everything
they're doing seeing and thinking is
correct because they just keep getting
richer
all the time and it leads you closer to
this
definition of evil which
in the book paradise lost friedman said
evil is the force which believes its
knowledge is complete
so these people become more and more
convinced
that they have the plan or they have
the course of action that will save the
world that if everyone would just listen
to them
that they would lead us to the promised
land right whether this is
bill gates saving us from a climate
crisis or
any of these other economic policies
that are targeted at a certain outcome
but almost
always diverge almost perfectly from
that outcome creating its opposite
effect
i think that's the problem that we have
this mechanism that can concentrate
wealth and power into the fan into the
hands of so few
that it leads to the proliferation of
evil
meaning that it convinces people that
their knowledge is complete whereas
something like a bitcoin almost forces
the opposite outcome
it in a bitcoin
denominated world a pure free market
the consumer is sovereign so you
cannot earn value in the world unless
you are serving
your fellow man unless they have through
expressed through their buy and sell
decisions in the marketplace right
you've created
a satisfaction of a particular want that
they value so much
they've acquired so much of your good or
service that you've become rich
you can only maintain that position of
wealth so long as you continue to serve
your fellow man
so it changes the incentives such that
dominance in the world is no longer
can no longer be paired with coercion it
has to be paired with competence
and it's that's that's how this when we
say bitcoin fixes this
that's what we mean like it restores
that skin in the game that balance of
incentives and disincentives that help
us properly navigate reality
and it prevents the buildup of systemic
rot
like we see with the central bank
you